right right it is going to be an awesome
night tonight after we get through what
could be our first triple digit day of
the year maybe we're going to be oh so
close and there will be some
neighborhoods that do hit that 100
degree Mark but we may not do it
officially we had upper 90s yesterday we
stayed away from triple digits again
over the weekend beautiful blue skies
temperatures in the 70s we're warming up
now as that sun has been up for just
about an hour or so so it is going to
get warmer and warmer and I think we'll
still see maybe a flare-up of some
showers or at least clouds over the
mountains this afternoon we've got 60s
in Pahrump and Indian Springs 70s
Mesquite Boulder City and near 80 in
Laughlin look at that still near 90
degrees in Death Valley with 50's in
Caliente and I think central Nevada will
be more of the focus for showers and
thunderstorms and over into the southern
Sierra so still 30s up there in Italy so
as I roll the wind forecast there is a
cold front further north that's going to
pick up Breezy South Southeast winds
this afternoon into this evening and
then again on Tuesday look for some of
those gusts that could reach 25 30 miles
an hour while sustained winds will be
between 15 and 20 miles an hour after
that we have quite a cool down coming so
it's all because of this cold front that
will stay mainly to the north of us but
again Breezy winds we'll have sunny
skies and highs very close to 100
degrees today if we don't do it today
we're not doing it for the rest of the
eight day forecast in fact we are
dipping into the upper 80s and low 90s
Tuesday Wednesday and then we go back up
but another system brings clouds for the
weekend and highs only in the 80s for
Sunday Monday June is going to be quite
interesting I think Nate